in the meantime we're heading into the
4th of july weekend with a reminder
from local blood banks they need you
well they need your blood
blood banks at critically low levels
right now are bianca holmen
at the start of a two day long blood
drive where is this bianca
[Music]
hey good morning so this is actually
going to be at the ram park casino jw
marriott hotel this is happening
july 3rd and 4th so you can make plans
happening all day you got to make an
appointment
to tell us more i'm joined by
representative from vitality brittany
estrella so thank you for joining us
this morning tell us
what you need what you're looking for
and how the community can help
right now there is a critical shortage
of blood in our community here in las
vegas and
also nationwide we're asking anyone of
all blood types to donate as there is a
severe shortage
specifically of type o negative and o
positive
if you'd like to come out this weekend
we'll be here all weekend at the rampart
casino
from 8 am to 5 pm on saturday and sunday
you can come out and donate on behalf of
hospital patients
who need their lives saved with a blood
transfusion yeah well tell us about that
process there may be a lot of people who
are not traveling this weekend so they
are in town i know summer time it can be
a little bit difficult to get people to
come out and donate
but maybe people are staying in town
what is that process like when they come
in and
again decide to donate blood it's a
quick process it takes about an hour of
your day to save a life the donation
itself takes about 10 to 12 minutes of
your time
we have our donation chair set up here
and our interview booth to
interview before your blood donation
takes place and just think about that
one hour spent of your time
to donate to save a hospital patient's
life it's a very
important experience especially right
now during the national critical blood
shortage
yeah and so again the pandemic impacted
us summer has impacted us
and how can people sign up give us the
details as far as sign up and i hear
there's also
a quick little incentive as well that's
right all donors um can visit
vitalent.org or call 87725 vital
like you said we're also giving out a
wet and wild admission to all donors and
a vitale t-shirt redeemable
via email all right perfect so coming up
in the next half hour we're going to
talk about
covet once you have your vaccine can you
still give blood if you've gotten covet
can you still give
she's going to definitely answer all
those questions coming up in the next
half hour back to you guys in the studio